Casi un 52% de los votos a favor y
más de un millón de diferencia
respecto a la alternativa de quedarse. El
pasado jueves 23 de junio el pueblo
británico determinó mediante referéndum
abandonar la Unión Europea,
nada más conocerse los resultados "¡boom"!
terremoto en los mercados europeos que
perdieron en la jornada del viernes
más de 300.000 millones de euros. "A un
escenario de pánico vendedor con
caídas similares a la quiebra de Lehman
Brothers de entre 10 y el 15 por ciento
en algunos mercados europeos"
Pero, ¿qué ha
llevado a los británicos a tomar una
decisión tan drástica? Bien, hoy aquí
en VisualPolitik queremos acercarnos a
sus razones porque nos lo habéis
pedido y también porque creemos que se ha manejado mucho desde los medios de
comunicación de habla hispana que han
achacado el resultado prácticamente
sólo la presencia de partidos y grupos
xenófobos cuando la realidad es mucho
más compleja: no sólo la mayoría de ciudadanos británicos han votado por
la salida sino que muchos de los
líderes políticos del Reino Unido la
apoyaban entre ellos siete de los
ministros de gobierno moderado y proeuropeo
de David Cameron.
Incluso la canciller Angela Merkel
reconocía el pasado mes de febrero que
el Reino Unido tenía mucha razón en
muchos de los planteamientos y demandas
realizadas. Entre los partidarios del
Brexit encontramos sí a quienes
están obsesionados por los movimientos
migratorios y los problemas de
inmigración pero también a quienes
piden reafirmar el libre mercado las
islas e incluso a quienes desde la
extrema izquierda
entiende que el Brexit representa un
punto de ruptura frente a un modelo
neoliberal que detestan. Nosotros hoy nos vamos a centrar en las principales
razones que se han esgrimido para
defender la salida de la Unión Europea
La pertenencia al mercado único ha
jugado como no podía ser de otra forma
un papel clave en todo el proceso y
frente a las amenazas los defensores del
Brexit se han mostrado tajantes
El proteccionismo y los aranceles
comunitarios, la PAC y las regulaciones
afectan gravemente al comercio
británico de hecho afirman que una vez
que se produzca la salida el Reino Unido no
va a tener ningún problema en llegar a un
acuerdo con la Unión Europea para
mantener su acceso al mercado único
porque afirman nadie en Europa está
dispuesto a renunciar a los más de
500.000 millones de euros que cada año
en exportaciones van rumbo a la isla.
Ojo, con un saldo positivo para la Unión
Europea de más de 180.000 millones de
dólares
Además los partidarios del Brexit recuerdan
que la economía británica cada vez es
menos dependiente del mercado único y
mucho más dependiente de potencias
extranjeras de potencias emergentes y de
hecho afirman que la salida les va a
permitir diseñar políticas comerciales
para acceder en mejores condiciones a
este tipo de mercados que tiene mucho
más potencial.
De hecho, los partidarios del Brexit niegan que mayor integración equivalga a
mayor prosperidad y para ello utilizan
las estadísticas que demuestran que
cuanto más se han integrado los países europeos más se ha desplomado su crecimiento
económico.
Y sí, tienen un modelo que se llama Suiza:
un país que no pertenece a la Unión
Europea pero que en exportaciones per
cápita multiplica por cinco al Reino
Unido cuyo pib per cápita es el doble
que el del Reino Unido y que tiene un
modelo de competitividad y de bienestar
que es uno de los más exitosos y
lugar a una de todo el mundo.
Los
defensores del Brexit no sólo consideraban
regulaciones comunitarias con un ataque
a su soberanía sino que también
entienden que suponen un grave perjuicio
para la economía británica
de hecho afirman que tan sólo el top
100 de regulaciones supuso el año
pasado un coste de más de 35 mil
millones de euros para la economía del
Reino Unido y además tampoco aceptan la incontinencia legislativa de la
Comunidad Europea que desde del año 2010 ha aprobado más de tres mil quinientas
leyes y reglamentos que afecta a las
empresas británicas dificultando su
capacidad para hacer negocios y mermando su competitividad. De hecho, como ejemplo
de esta excesiva regulación ponen sobre
la mesa las 109 regulaciones que afectan
unas almohadas las 50 regulaciones sobre el edredones y sábanas o las 31
regulaciones que detallan cómo tienen
que funcionar los mercados de cepillos
de dientes y es que incluso denuncian
los partidarios del Brexit que la
comunidad europea ha regulado el tamaño de los kiwis.
Punto clave en la campaña sobre todo entre populistas y nacionalistas.
Los británicos quieren controlar sus fronteras y de hecho
quieren implantar un sistema de
inmigración equivalente al de Australia.
Es decir, que dé prioridad a la cualificación de los inmigrantes por encima de otros criterios.
En los últimos años hay que decir que la economía
británica machado relativamente bien.
De hecho, el empleo se encuentra en las cotas más altas de toda la historia con lo
que muchos inmigrantes han llegado a las islas.
"Mira los números, la migración neta en Reino Unido se acerca a su récord y no tenemos ningún
control por parte de la Unión Europea.
Tan sólo el pasado año en términos
netos más de 330 mil personas se
desplazaron al Reino Unido en busca de
un trabajo y claro esto ha sido
aprovechado por grupos de presión para
generar un caldo de cultivo nacionalista
entre otras cosas por las elevadas
prestaciones sociales que existen en
este país y que generan un efecto
distorsionador enorme cuando llegan de
golpe muchos inmigrantes.
Reino Unido es el segundo donante neto de la Unión Europea y su aportación
insisto en términos netos ronda los 200
millones de euros semanales y hay que
decir que en las instituciones comunitarias ni por supuesto su burocracia son ni han
sido nunca particularmente populares
entre la ciudadanía británica.
De hecho ya desde los tiempos de Wilson y Thatcher los británicos se han negado
específicamente a ser los paganinis de
la fiesta europea. Hay que decir que
reunido accedió a la comunidad en 1973
y ya en 1975 apenas dos años más tarde
habían planteado un referéndum para
modificar las condiciones de adhesión
por considerarlas injustas y fue poco
más tarde en 1979 cuando Margaret
Thatcher pronunció su célebre: "NO, NO, NO!"
Es innegable que las instituciones europeas no son un modelo de calidad
democrática y no lo digo sólo por la
dispersión y alejanía del voto que
provoca su enorme extensión sino porque
en el día a día en la toma de
decisiones la opinión de los electores
es intrascendente.
La Unión Europea es el paraíso de los burócratas y las élites
por cierto viven prácticamente
en el anonimato y nunca se sabe a
ciencia cierta quién toma las decisiones ni cómo se toman ni quién influye en ellas.
Claro, en esta tesitura no es difícil entender que para un pueblo
como el británico acostumbrado a una
democracia muy participativa donde los
ciudadanos conocen directamente a sus
representantes no les parezca muy
compatible esta pseudodemocracia con la defensa de las libertades.
¿Quién es usted ni yo ni nadie en Europa
ha oído hablar nunca de usted?
Quiero preguntarle quién le votó para
ser presidente.
Bueno y vosotros qué pensáis del Brexit, ¿Créeis que se está abriendo un período de
cambio en la UE?
¿Pensáis que nuevos países seguirán
los pasos del Reino Unido en su aventura
de desconexión? Bueno, si os doy mi opinión, yo soy contrario al Brexit pero porque soy español:
si fuese británico, no lo tendría tan claro. Espero vuestros
comentarios para abrir un debate,
espero que os haya gustado del vídeo,
un saludo y hasta la próxima!